wouldn't it be possible one day to kind
of change the way people think for
instance something like racism you would
be able to kind of dial that down
there's a deep morality dimension of
that too because that means you're
controlling people's thoughts I think
it's like so many things there there's
probably a potential to do bad and
there's also a great potential to do
good I was involved in a trial where we
put electrodes in to try to help people
with otherwise incurable depression so
all of these things have the potential
for good or bad I'm hoping that
Elementary education gets rid of racism
in this country rather than having to
put electrodes in everyone's seems the
less risky uh approach I got to tell you
the way things are going I'm betting on
you
[Laughter]